Jennifer Aniston revealing her secret
struggle to have a baby Sometimes women
get into marriages relationships or
whatever whatever however it looks and
they can't have children so the choices
are so vast now that's Jen on the cover
of Allure It's the mag's final print
issue and inside she gets candid about
the heart she went through in her 30s
and 40s quote I was trying to get
pregnant it was a challenging Road for
me the baby making Road she goes on to
confess she tried every means possible
to conceive including IVF while facing
years of speculation from the world the
world is waiting for you guys to get
pregnant this must drive you nuts it's
amusing it's also what it was kind of a
couple of the months so that'll pass
you know somebody else will fill the
slot quote it was really hard I was
throwing everything at it I would have
given anything if someone had said to me
freeze your eggs do yourself a favor you
just don't think it so here I am today
the ship has sailed now Jen says she's
moved on from trying to have a
biological child of her own quote I have
zero regrets I actually feel a little
relief now because there is no more can
I maybe maybe maybe I don't have to
think about that anymore of course Jen
was married to Brad Pitt from 2000 to
2005. now we get to enjoy the night and
go to work but that we can we can do it
all we're sleeping we're 80. and Justin
Thoreau from 2015 to 2017. I got a good
one I got a sweet kind man yeah I
literally think that every day like wake
up and feel very lucky I feel very
fortunate yeah and she addresses the
speculation around her failed marriages
saying that the public narrative that
she only cared about her career and
didn't want children was quote absolute
lies so is Jen open to finding love
again she tells the mag Never Say Never
adding that she'd love a relationship
stay excited and possibly something will
happen and while Jen hasn't detailed her
fertility struggles in the past she did
pen a 2016 piece for the Huffington Post
about the pregnancy rumors that have
surrounded her for years writing in part
quote for the record I am not pregnant
what I am is fed up we don't need to be
married or mothers to be complete
it doesn't look as as the sort of
picture-perfect father mother little
kid's dog named spot pick it how you
know picket fence and all that stuff
it's it comes in you know two daddies
two mommies single mommy single daddies
married couple I mean it doesn't you
know now Jen tells Allure that she's
done protecting her IVF story and plans
to write a book quote the world creates
narratives that aren't true so I might
as well tell the truth I feel like I'm
coming out of hibernation I don't have
anything to hide
foreign
[Music]